Dangerous driving, falling for the
wrong person, and dancing with cartoon
birds. These movies really tested the
limits of how much an actor could take!
The dark, claustrophobic sets and constantly
gushing water made for some difficult days
on the set of James Cameron's 1989 sci-fi
flick The Abyss. But one day stands out for
Mary Elizabeth Mastrantonio. While filming a
scene in which Ed Harris performs CPR on her,
Cameron directed Harris to actually
slap Mastrantonio. He had to repeat
the slap when the take was
obstructed by Harris' arm.
After the next take was botched
when the camera ran out of film,
Mastrantonio actually got up and left
the set. She stayed away for hours,
leaving Harris to practice with a sandbag until
she was ready to finish filming the scene.
Captain America: Civil War focuses
on the rift between the Avengers as
the U.S. government tries to limit
their reach. This new oversight is
partially inspired by the exploits of
the Winter Soldier, aka Bucky Barnes,
who is being pursued by various factions. In an
attempt to keep his old friend out of harm's way,
Steve Rogers — played by Chris Evans —
tries to get to him before anyone else can.
In a dramatic chase scene, Bucky attempts
to escape by flying away in a helicopter.
This prompts Rogers to try to keep the powerful
vehicle grounded with his own two hands. In an
impressive feat of strength, he actually manages
to bring the helicopter crashing down. However,
filming this scene was so intense that it left him
injured. Speaking to ET Online, Evans remarked,
"And I actually messed up my
arm doing it, I really did."
According to Evans, this stunt wasn't
created through special effects:
He's truly straining to keep this
helicopter under control. He explained,
"It's a fake helicopter, obviously, but it
was drifting beyond the ability of control.
I tweaked a little something. To
this day, I'm still messed up."
While on the set of his 2002 thriller Panic Room,
director David Fincher told The New York Times,
"I felt like I needed to be more
attentive to watching the actors."
He put that theory into motion for his next
film, Zodiac — a period piece about the search
for the "Zodiac Killer" who murdered their
way through Northern California in the 1970s.
Jake Gyllenhaal, who starred as
cartoonist-turned-crime reporter
Robert Graysmith, bore the brunt of Fincher's
commitment to putting his actors through the
wringer. According to Gyllenhaal, for
one scene, Fincher required 70 takes;
for another, he asked for 90. Plus,
because the film was shot digitally,
Fincher could spontaneously delete a slew
of takes all at once. Gyllenhaal said,
"But there is a stopping point.
There's a point at which you go,
'That's what we have to work with.'
But we would reshoot things."
Although it was far from her first major role,
Kate Winslet's performance in Titanic launched
her to worldwide stardom, but filming the
movie was not a pleasant experience. The
Telegraph reports that there were multiple
issues on set that caused both the cast and
crew to question whether they wanted
to remain part of the project at all.
"But this ship can't sink."
"She's made of iron sir. I assure you, she can."
One particularly troubling moment came
when Winslet filmed a scene in the water.
According to The Times, she genuinely feared
she might drown in the set's gargantuan water
tank. Things were so rough, she even
expressed a desire to steer clear of
director James Cameron in the future. As
reported by The Guardian, Winslet said,
"He has a temper like you wouldn't
believe. [...] You'd have to pay
me a lot of money to work with Jim again."
Years later, however, she softened her stance:
The pair collaborated on Avatar: The Way of Water.
Quentin Tarantino's "Kill Bill" movies follow
Beatrix Kiddo, aka the Bride, as she seeks revenge
on the Deadly Viper Assassination Squad. Years
earlier, the group betrayed her by killing her
groom-to-be and putting her in a coma. Now she's
back on her feet and ready to dispense justice.
Uma Thurman shines as the deadly Kiddo, earning
international acclaim for her performance.
In the second movie, a scene in which Kiddo
drives a car with steely determination proved
to be problematic. As The New
York Times eventually revealed,
Tarantino pushed Thurman to drive the vehicle
herself, despite her well-founded concerns
that it would be unsafe. Those fears were
soon justified when the car hit a tree,
causing serious injuries that Thurman still deals
with to this day. She revealed that immediately
after the incident, she was scared she would
be unable to walk again. Thurman remarked,
"I went from being a creative contributor
and performer to being like a broken tool."
After a 15-year battle to
get footage of the crash,
Tarantino finally surrendered it to
Thurman. But, as Thurman herself noted,
this can't undo the damage that was
done, or the pain that still lingers.
In the 1993 film What's Eating Gilbert Grape?,
Johnny Depp starred as the titular Gilbert — a
guy stuck in a small town caring for his
developmentally disabled younger brother
and their housebound mother. Cast as the mom was
Darlene Cates, an acting novice that director
Lasse Hallström spotted on The Sally Jessy Raphael
Show discussing her own struggle with obesity.
Depp was going through some personal stuff during
the film's shoot and was using alcohol to cope.
Hallström later told Entertainment Weekly that he
also empathized with his character a bit too much:
"It was more that he could relate to the troubled
family life and the desire to get
out of a small-town situation."
Depp was in such a sensitive place that
he had trouble filming scenes where his
character had to make disparaging comments
about his mother. Cates recalled that each
night after those scenes were shot, Depp
called her to apologize. She explained,
"Here he is the professional; he's done all this
stuff before. But I thought, 'What a tribute
to his kindness that he would take the time to
consider that I might be hurt by what he said.'"
"You're my knight in shimmering
armor. Did you know that?"
To do his job killing bad guys
and foiling terrorist plots,
007 needs to use a firearm on occasion.
*guns firing*
One of the actors who portrayed Bond onscreen
had a really hard time with those moments.
Roger Moore starred in seven 007 movies,
including The Spy Who Loved Me, Moonraker,
and, ironically, The Man with the Golden Gun.
While he doesn't regret playing James Bond,
according to the BBC, Moore once said,
"I regret that sadly heroes in general
are depicted with guns in their hands,
and to tell the truth I have always
hated guns and what they represent."
It all goes back to his childhood. In his memoir
"My Word is My Bond," Moore said that as a boy,
he was rendered deaf for a few days when a
gun "blew up" in his hands. A few years later,
a friend shot a BB gun into the future star's
leg. When he'd have to use a firearm onscreen,
Moore would squeeze his eyes tightly in
discomfort as he pulled the trigger on
his prop Walther PPK firearm. By the
time he filmed his final Bond movie,
he publicly lamented that the film
series had, quote, "turned so violent."
In Quentin Tarantino's Django Unchained,
Jamie Foxx plays Django Freeman — a formerly
enslaved man who joins Dr. King Schultz to
rescue his wife from fearsome plantation owner
Calvin J. Candie, played by Leonardo DiCaprio.
As you would expect from a Tarantino movie,
"Django Unchained" contains lots of stylized
violence, gory fight scenes, and plenty
of foul language, including a number of
racist slurs. DiCaprio took issue with his
dialogue, which required him to use these
ugly terms multiple times. As Metro.co.uk
revealed, the actor needed outside advice to
move forward with the brutal script: Both Foxx
and Samuel L. Jackson urged him to perform the
dialogue as it was written for the sake of
authenticity. Though he did manage to move
forward, DiCaprio said that he found playing
Candie incredibly tough. The actor remarked,
"It was this incredibly interesting
horrific character. I mean,
there was absolutely nothing about
this man I could identify with."
The psychological horror film Black Swan is
memorable for many reasons. It was a huge box
office hit, earning more than $300 million
against its budget of $13 million. It also
won a vast array of awards, including
five nominations from the 2011 Oscars.
Natalie Portman stars as promising
ballet dancer Nina Sayers,
who struggles to cope with the demands
of portraying the dual role of Odette
and Odile in Tchaikovsky's "Swan Lake." She
soon forms a rivalry with fellow dancer Lily,
played by Mila Kunis, and slowly
begins to lose touch with reality.
At one point in the film, Kunis and Portman's
characters lock themselves in a room and end
up in bed together — a scene that was something
of a trial for both actresses. In an interview
with Parade, Kunis revealed that she and
Portman knew the scene would be a hot topic.
"It wasn't done for shock value, but we
weren't looking forward to it. I don't
think we were laughing between takes.
I think we were like, 'Let's just get
this over with.' It's uncomfortable
doing a sex scene. It's just bizarre."
Portman confirmed this in a
conversation with MTV News:
"It was pretty awkward. I
almost feel like it would
be easier to do it with someone you didn't know."
That said, both Portman and Kunis agreed that
their friendship made the whole process smoother.
Before Horrible Bosses, there was 9 to 5.
This dark comedy from 1980 centered on three
overworked, overlooked female secretaries enacting
brutal revenge on a chauvinistic pig of a manager,
played by Dabney Coleman. Dolly Parton, Lily
Tomlin, and Jane Fonda headed up the cast,
with Fonda also producing. But a mere week
after filming began, Tomlin tried to quit.
What set off the legendary comic actress?
She watched the raw footage of herself and
was embarrassed by her performance
— particularly the scenes for a Snow
White-inspired animated fantasy
sequence where she acted opposite
a yet-to-be-created cartoon bird. On The Late
Show with Stephen Colbert, Tomlin explained,
"And I was talking to the
birds that weren't there…"
"Oh yeah?"
"And I was not doing a good job. And I thought,
'Oh this is, I'm going to be horrible in this.'"
Despite her reservations, she stuck with
the film, and an '80s classic was born.
During production of the first Fast and Furious
movie, series regular and all-around badass
Michelle Rodriguez actually considered walking
away over concerns with the way her character,
Letty Ortiz, was written. Specifically, Rodriguez
took issue with the way the script called for
Letty to betray her true love Dom and fall for
undercover cop Brian. She felt this betrayal made
no sense for a woman who clearly preferred,
in her words, "the alpha-est of alpha males"
to a pretty boy. Refusing to compromise her
vision of Letty, Rodriguez put her foot down,
telling producers she'd quit the movie if she
had to. Fortunately for Fast and Furious fans,
the storyline was tweaked to Rodriguez's
liking, and the rest is blockbuster history.
Starring in one of the most anticipated
movies of the century is an opportunity
most actors would kill for. But the
pressure of filming 2015's Star Wars:
The Force Awakens nearly proved too much for Daisy
Ridley. The British newcomer didn't have much
experience before J.J. Abrams cast her as Rey,
and Screen Rant reports she almost quit on the
first day when he told her that her performance
during a desert scene felt "wooden." That note,
along with bearing the weight of the biggest
franchise in movie history, almost prompted Ridley
to get on a spaceship to anywhere far, far away.
Shelley Duvall set a Guinness World Record for her
portrayal of Wendy in Stanley Kubrick's 1980
horror classic The Shining – but it's not a
record anyone would want. The perfectionist
Kubrick insisted on 127 takes of the scene
where Duvall's hysterical character uses a bat to
fend off a deranged Jack Nicholson. By the end,
she so was exhausted and dehydrated from
crying that she nearly quit. She didn't,
but the stress of filming the scene was bad
enough that she reportedly began losing her hair.
Before she landed leading roles in huge
blockbusters like Avatar and Guardians of
the Galaxy, Saldana was just another struggling
actress getting by on bit parts. She had a small
one as Anamaria in 2003's Pirates of the
Caribbean: The Curse of the Black Pearl,
and she said she was treated so badly that she
nearly quit, telling The Hollywood Reporter,
"It was very elitist. People
disrespecting me because they
look at my number on a call sheet
and they think I'm not important."
It was so demoralizing, Saldana said she
even considered quitting acting altogether.
Mike Myers created the character of
Wayne Campbell on Saturday Night Live,
and the recurring sketch became so popular
that Paramount wanted a Wayne's World movie.
Myers wrote the screenplay, and he was
especially excited about the scene where
Wayne and the boys pack into the Mirthmobile
and headbang to Queen's "Bohemian Rhapsody."
But the studio wanted to replace the
song with something fresher and cheaper
to license. Myers thought the Queen song was
crucial, as he revealed on WTF with Marc Maron.
Both Myers and Bohemian Rhapsody stayed.
Gene Hackman won an Oscar for his turn as New
York City police detective Jimmy "Popeye" Doyle
in 1971's The French Connection, but it almost
didn't happen. A notoriously difficult actor,
he often clashed with director William Friedkin,
especially after Friedkin revealed Paul Newman
was his first choice for the part. Things came to
a head during a scene where Hackman – dressed in
a Santa Claus costume – tackles a criminal on the
street. Friedkin demanded 27 takes, and Hackman
nearly quit. Fortunately, he stayed and even
mentioned it in his speech at the Academy Awards.
Few wrestling stars are bigger than John Cena,
so when WWE produced the direct to video cop
thriller 12 Rounds in 2009, casting him as
the lead was a no brainer. Although his day
job is to battle hulking beasts in the ring,
Cena apparently isn't fearless. One scene called
for his character to rappel down a skyscraper
and dangle mid-air from a rope. But Cena
revealed later that his severe fear of heights
triggered intense anxiety and he considered
walking away before he ever got up there.
A big part of the fourth Rocky movie
involves Rocky's mentor, Apollo Creed,
staging a comeback. Played by former NFL
linebacker Carl Weathers, Creed gets roughed
up in the ring pretty bad by Communist pugilist
Ivan Drago, played by Dolph Lundgren. But one
of the boxing scenes got a little too real
when Lundgren threw Weathers into a corner,
causing Weathers to break character and throw a
real punch. Lundgren responded in kind, knocking
Weathers out. When he regained consciousness, he
quit the movie and sent production into limbo for
four days. That's when Sylvester Stallone
finally convinced Weathers to return.
Alfred Hitchcock had a reputation for being unkind
to actresses, but Tippi Hedren signed on to 1963's
The Birds under the guarantee that she'd only be
attacked with mechanical birds during the film's
climactic scene. But Hitchcock is the king of
twists, and he wanted Hedren's terror to feel
real, so he instructed crew members to throw
real, live birds at her. This real-life game
of Angry Birds went on for five full days and
Hedren had a breakdown when it was over. She
only finished the movie when a doctor ordered
Hitchcock to give her a week off to recover.
The Walking Dead nearly suffered what would
have been a devastating loss in Season 3,
when Lauren Cohan, who plays Maggie, contemplated
quitting over a particularly stressful scene.
After reading the script and realizing Maggie
was supposed to perform an emergency c-section
on Lori Grimes — while the character's son looked
on — she took her concerns to co-star Steven Yeun,
explaining she was worried it would be too
intense. But after further consideration, that's
exactly why she decided to stay. Recognizing that
The Walking Dead is a show about people pushed to
grueling extremes, she drew on her discomfort
to deliver an affectingly honest performance.
You think you hated Fox's first couple of
Fantastic Four movies? Try being Jessica Alba,
whose experiences playing Sue "Invisible
Woman" Storm nearly made her walk away from
acting altogether. Alba's frustrations stemmed
from working with director Tim Story, who she
later claimed issued absurd demands like telling
her to keep her facial expression flat during a
crying scene so she'd stay "pretty." After 2007's
Rise of the Silver Surfer, she realized she didn't
care about the movie business anymore, and has
been more selective about acting projects. But
things have still worked out pretty well for her
— she went on to co-found the Honest Company,
currently valued around $1 billion.
Interview with the Vampire united Tom
Cruise and Brad Pitt in a visually sumptuous
adaptation of the bestselling Anne Rice novel,
but being part of 1994's most eagerly anticipated
beefcake summit wasn't all it was cracked up to
be for Pitt. Years after the movie came and went,
Pitt admitted he was so miserable during filming
that he actually approached producer David Geffen
about buying out his contract — only to reconsider
after Geffen informed him it'd cost $40 million.
It's hard to imagine Gandalf being played by
anyone other than Sir Ian McKellen, who played
the wizard in all six Lord of the Rings and Hobbit
films. But if things had worked out a little
differently during the filming of The Hobbit:
An Unexpected Journey, director Peter Jackson
might've had to find a different actor. That's
because McKellen was acting almost exclusively
to a green, screen since his character towered
over the hobbits and their interactions had to
be stitched together digitally. The frustration
of acting alone eventually got to McKellen, who
broke down on the set at one point. Jackson did
a little emergency outreach to convince
him to stick around, and the crew held a
"Gandalf Appreciation Day," and decorated
his tent with Lord of the Rings mementos.
Marvel's The Avengers was such a huge, ambitious
project that it attracted actors who usually
don't do comic book movies, including two-time
Oscar nominee Jeremy Renner as Clint Barton,
a.k.a. Hawkeye. While some of the more famous
heroes in the movie — like Iron Man, the Hulk,
Captain America — got to do more interesting
things, Hawkeye spent most of The Avengers as
the brainwashed servant of villain Loki. Renner
was...displeased. He explained during a Q&A event:
"I was just getting to know who Hawkeye was,
and then zap, I go round like a
zombie. I'm like Loki's minion."
But don't worry, Renner took it like a champ.
Haha, just kidding! He sulked and whined about it.
He later recalled that in each
scene, he'd make horrible,
audible grunts of pain. When
asked why by the crew, he said:
"I'm giving you an option, if you just want
to kick me out of this movie. Just you know,
at any given moment, if you wanna kill me
off, daddy’s gonna be having a heart attack."